les titres les affrontements continuent
à mogadiscio et l'onu envisage d'en
d'évacuer les étrangers assurant l'aide
humanitaire là bas la crise de la pêche
la commission de bruxelles a annoncé
aujourd'hui l'instauration de prix de
vente minimum pour les importations de
certaines espèces de poissons mesure
qualifiée d'insuffisante par les
pêcheurs le monde politique que
rassembler tous courants confondus aux
obsèques de jean lecanuet à rouen un
français sur cinq pourrait être
considéré comme un raciste convaincu
c'est l'une des conclusions du rapport
de la commission des droits de l'homme
nous terminons ce journal avec le couple
de l'année sophie marceau et lambert
wilson réunis sur les planches pour le
pygmalion de bernard shaw madame
monsieur bonsoir la dépêche indique
cessez le feu relativement solide à
sarajevo
derrière la sécheresse des mots se
cachent de terribles drames certes avant
cessez-le-feu proclamé unilatéralement
par les bosniaques dimanche dernier 400
à 1000 au but de toutes sortes
s'abattaient quotidiennement sur
sarajevo
les tirs d'artillerie sont infiniment
moins nombreux mais ils font encore des
victimes exemple cette petite fille de
deux ans portés en terre ce matin par
ses parents comment père dorothée
olliéric elle n'avait que deux ans el
médina
elle n'avait que deux ans et elle était
musulmane une enfant a été enterré
aujourd'hui dans le grand cimetière de
sarajevo
selon le gouvernement bosniaque 1800
gosses ont été tuées en dix mois de
guerre
rien que dans la capitale pour l'onu
jamais les enfants avaient payé un telle
tribu dans les derniers conflits jamais
dit le père d'un médina je ne lèverai ce
sens parce que jamais je n'oublierai le
crime des serbes
lavigne shatter et musulmans son
histoire c'est celle de la guerre
l'histoire d'une vie brisée par la
guerre de ce jour où l'obus est tombé
chez eux
sa femme a reçu des éclats d'obus
mais elle pleure sa fille et dit à son
mari pourquoi dieu nous at il repris
celle qui nous avait donné c'était le
premier jour du ramadan l'obus est tombé
du ciel un enfer ici trois générations
cohabitent est et ce jour là
à la nuit tombée ils passaient à table
le destin les a surpris c'était un jour
presque comme les autres dans le vieux
quartier musulman le deuil de cette
famille c'est un peu le deuil de toute
une communauté
il neigeait aujourd'hui à sarajevo al
médina n'avait que deux ans les combats
s'aggrave à mogadiscio les responsables
de l'onu envisage très sérieusement
d'évacuer les étrangers assurant l'aide
humanitaire en somalie la capitale de ce
pays a été aujourd'hui le théâtre des
affrontements armés les plus sérieux
depuis le début de l'opération rendre
l'espoir le 8 décembre dernier bernard
lebrun
des balles sifflent aux oreilles de la
foule et des marines course effrénée des
soldats en direction du tir mouvement de
foule
un maillot il revient avec un prisonnier
molesté bureau
le tireur non un gamin somaliens fini
avec ça m'a aussi vite interpellé que
relâche
km 4 au coeur de mogadiscio à deux pas
de l'ambassade américaine manches de
pioche en main un autre marine contrôler
les passants et le manche de pioche
n'est pas une canne c'est aussi une arme
disperser les manifestants
deuxième jour d'émeutes à mogadiscio
premier bilan officiel
5 more year et un aujourd'hui parmi les
somaliens trois américains et deux
soldats nigérians placé ce matin
l'ambassade égyptienne totalement pillé
le calme semble avoir été établi cet
après midi mais l'alerté a été sérieux
au point que l'onu annonce l'éventuelle
évacuation du personnel humanitaire ce
serait un terrible échec
l'humanitaire les militaires étaient
venus pour cela au départ
intensification de la guerre civile en
angola où les combats auraient fait au
moins 500 morts parmi la population
civile à huambo la deuxième ville de ce
pays
attention également au sénégal où les
résultats du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle tarde décidément à être
rendu public
quatre jours après ce scrutin les
sénégalais se cherche toujours un
président reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux richard biner beurre numério ce
n'est pas encore l'état d'urgence mais
plus tout à fait la vraie démocratie
alors que les sénégalais ne connaissent
toujours pas le nom du président qu'ils
sont élus dimanche des blindés ont pris
position dans dakar le corps d'élite de
la gendarmerie protège la télévision un
char et postés en permanence devant le
pds le principal parti d'opposition
l'adie matin on a vu que la police avait
pris position durant la nuit devant nos
locaux
on ne sait pas vraiment pourquoi on est
un parti politique et ils n'ont rien à
nous reprocher le palais de justice est
sous haute surveillance
la commission chargée du recensement des
voix composé des représentants des huit
candidats et de la présidente de la cour
d'appel s'est enlisé les membres de la
commission sont là pour défendre les
intérêts de leur candidat c'est ir1
disons les choses un peu difficiles
cinq jours après le scrutin le sénégal
cherche toujours son président le parti
socialiste d'un abdou diouf à coeur
abdoulaye wade son vieux rival affirme
qu'il est élu est aujourd'hui vous vous
considérez comme le président élu du
sénégal
écoutez j'ai le sentiment a été élu mais
je ne suis pas encore confirmé par une
décision judiciaire parce qu'il faut un
arrêt pour cela mais en tout cas ce
qu'il a fait je suis convaincu que j'ai
été choisi par le sénégal après cinq ans
de trêve le combat des chefs a repris la
commission nationale de recensement des
voix devra rapidement proclamé le
scrutin les sénégalais sont las
d'attendre et dans cette démocratie la
plus ancienne d'afrique
on n'aime guère voir les blindés dans la
rue retour en france avec tout d'abord
les suites de la crise de la pêche la
commission de bruxelles a annoncé
aujourd'hui l'instauration d'un prix de
vente minimum pour les importations de
certaines espèces de poissons dans la
communauté mesure d'ores et déjà
qualifiée d'insuffisante par les
représentants des marins pêcheurs
bretons commentaires de notre envoyé
spécial à bruxelles jean todt renault
pression maximum pour les douze
directeur de la pêche réunis en comité
de gestion dans un immeuble de bruxelles
transformée en bunker dehors 400 marins
pêcheurs français manifestation calme
malgré quelques vitres brisées à coups
de fusées de détresse mais les excités
sont vite repris hier à l'heure du
déjeuner le directeur on sait de la
pêche apporte de la nouvelle la
commission fixe des prix minimum pendant
quatre mois pour les importations de
cabillaud ou le merlu de lieu noir
d'églefin et de lot mais pas de quotas
d'importation pour les pêcheurs du pays
bigouden
ce n'est pas suffisant il faudra
également intervenir sur les quotas
seraient quotas d'importation pas
question de quotas
rétorque que la commission de bruxelles
mais elle n'exclut pas de frapper plus
fort si le nous avons déjà signalé à les
autorités des pays tiers ne demande à
l'ambassadeur réussie de la pologne de
l'islande la norvège que si les
si il ne contrôle pas le péché les
réactions il y a toujours les mesures
extrêmes d'avoir un prêt mission total
voilà les policiers sont partis les
manifestants aussi pour une fois la
communauté européenne a réagi très vite
à bruxelles on espère que les marins
pêcheurs français ont d'abord évaluer
l'effet des mesures prises avant de
repasser à l'action lés responsables
politiques français de tous bords se
sont rassemblés ce matin la cathédrale
de rouen pour les obsèques de jean
lecanuet les habitants de la ville
s'étaient massés aux abords de la
cathédrale pour rendre un dernier
hommage à celui qui fut leur mère
pendant un quart de siècle
reportage bruno roger petit eric de
lannion l'hommage simple d'une ville à
son maire disparu
anonyme badauds curieux tous étaient
venus ce matin accompagné jean lecanuet
dans son dernier voyage
ce fut une lente procession à travers
les rues de la vieille ville de roy sur
le parvis de la cathédrale attendait les
politiques
pêle-mêle jacques chirac raymond barre
laurent fabius mais aussi françois
léotard charles pasqua pierre
méhaignerie et beaucoup d'autres encore
honneurs militaires rendus en présence
de pierre bérégovoy premier ministre
valéry giscard d'estaing présent
également avaient déjà pris place dans
la cathédrale au titre d' ami de la
famille
après la cérémonie l'inhumation a eu
lieu dans la plus stricte intimité
familiale
c'était là la dernière volonté de jean
lecanuet les législatives maintenant
avec les écologistes décidément au
centre de la bataille
invité hier soir de la marche du siècle
sur france3 brice lalonde et antoine
waechter ont tenu à réaffirmer
l'autonomie électorale des écologistes
antoine waechter a estimé qu'il faudrait
des années pour que socialistes et
écologistes deviennent des partenaires
quant à brice lalonde qui accepte la
main tendue de michel rocard pour
recomposer la gauche il a affirmé oui
aux bangs rocardien mais non aux gangs
socialiste le rpr fait lui aussi les
yeux doux aux électeurs écologistes
le mouvement que jacques chirac a en
effet présenté aujourd'hui une charte de
cet engagement pour l'environnement
pascal golomer qu'on se le dise le rpr m
le vert pas seulement les petits oiseaux
non l'environnement au sens large
aménagement du territoire économie
d'énergie couche d'ozone tout est résumé
en cet engagement dans une charte verte
évidemment mais sur papier non recyclé
une charte pour dire aux écologistes que
plutôt de commenter le big bang il
ferait mieux de s'occuper d'écologie
avec la droite de préférence comme il
nous l'avons fait dans les temps un
certain nombre de régions
nous sommes capables de passer avec les
écologistes
un contrat de travail c'est à dire un
contrat de travail sur les questions de
fond et non pas de mener des opérations
politiciennes
les leaders de l'opposition et les
écologistes se connaissent bien à
présent
dîner débat ou rencontre discrète ils
n'en sont plus à leur premier rang dim
un dialogue que brice lalonde juge
pourtant aujourd'hui sans issue faute
d'interlocuteur et de proposition à son
goût
il se trouve en cependant que dans
l'opposition ils sont tellement sûrs
d'arriver au pouvoir dans quelques jours
qui se partagent déjà les ministères et
que c'est le rideau est terminée et
fermer la longue ferme donc lui aussi le
rideau et ouvre la fenêtre à rocard lui
vers eux se disent toujours ouvert au
dialogue mais pas question de recevoir
des leçons d'écologie de la part de la
droite il y a des engagements qui sont
intéressants mais ce sont les
engagements très généraux et je suis
obligé de constater que dans les
communes dans les régions qu'ils gèrent
les élus rpr mènent des politiques
contradictoires
sauf là où les écologistes sont
suffisamment pesant pour produire des
inflexions
une chose paraît sûre en tout cas
aujourd'hui il n'y aura pas
d'écologistes ministère de
l'environnement dans un gouvernement de
droite
pendant ces grandes manoeuvres jean
marie le pen fait campagne à nice dans
la troisième circonscription des
alpes-maritimes
le président du front national a pris
l'autobus ce matin jusqu'à un quartier
défavorisé
afin de montrer l'intérêt qu'il porte
aux problèmes de sécurité ou
d'insécurité
portrait d'une circonscription chaude
avec notre correspondante valérie ermite
de jouer par semaine jean-marie le pen
bien sentir le bonheur de sa
circonscription
à baladrouz superbe au pas de charge il
vient chérir la nouvelle élue de son
coeur
nice il ne l'a pas choisi par hasard
nice lui offrent ses meilleurs scores au
niveau national du coup jean marie le
pen s'y sentent à l'aise et multiplie
ses visites surprises je veux juger
comme ici à l'ariane l'un des quartiers
chauds de la ville une compagnie qu'il
mène sur ses thèmes favoris et rêve d'un
siège de député à jesper la victoire je
pense je suis arrivé au premier tour je
pense très loin en tête
et si normalement il n'ya pas un partage
gauche droite où une triangulaire je
pense que je gagne les élections
la victoire jean-marie le pen n'est pas
le seul à y croire
en face rudy salles député udf sortant a
un avantage certain à nice il est chez
lui et dont le sud
être chez soi cela veut dire quelque
chose mais par nesta pas envie d'avoir
une étiquette front national
d'autre part nsa horreur des parachutés
sur le pen réuni 7 aux caractériques
pour tous les scores risque d'être très
serrée car rudy salles est attaqué sur
toutes ces droite bernard asso
conseiller général rpr a lui aussi
décidé de monter au créneau
une division à droite pour dit-il
ratisser plus large
un calcul particulier dont pourrait bien
tirer profit au premier tour les
socialistes jean hugues colonna et
peut-être aussi jean marie le pen pour
qui rien n'est gagné
seule inconnue la participation le
nombre exact de candidats mais surtout
le report des voix au second club
si la droite resserrent les rangs rien
n'est joué pour jean marie le pen
il a beau et mousse le pestis et une
niçoise
nice ne l'a pas encore tout à fait
adopter la campagne législative sur
france 2 avec ce soir la deuxième
édition d'auditions publiques émission
animée par paul amar qui va tout de
suite nous présenter les invités et les
thèmes retenus ce soir oui bruno beaux
soirs nous ne parlerons pas du big bang
ce soir mais de no big problème par
exemple de l'école où le sentiment
d'échec peut apparaître chez les
enseignants et chez les élèves ou
parfois par est aussi la drogue le
racket et la violence nous parlons aussi
de la justice perçu parfois par les
citoyens comme lointaine ou trop lente
nous parlerons enfin des relations entre
le monde politique et le monde de
l'argent voilà l'objet du débat qui
opposera la majorité présidentielle elle
sera représentée par lionel jospin et
michel sapin à l'opposition rpr udf qui
sera représentée par jacques toubon et
françois bayrou
interviendront également les
représentants des autres
artix antoine waechter pour les verts
gisèle moreau pour le parti communiste
et bruno mégret pour le front national
ce débat d'une heure et trente minutes
sera peut-être vif à l'image du premier
mais nous ferons tout pour que la
polémique si elle éclate n'occulte pas
le dialogue nécessaire entre les hommes
politiques et les français ces français
seront sont déjà présents sur le plateau
nous entendrons une enseignante une
lycéenne un magistrat et un chef
d'entreprise ce dialogue aura lieu
également avec les téléspectateurs grâce
au minitel 36 15 codes france 2 des
questions nombreux sont déjà posées
elles nous serviront d'indicateurs sur
l'état de la france sur les
préoccupations des français sur les
attentes des français
et elles seront j'en suis sûr d'une aide
précieuse pour nos hommes politiques
aient leur permettront peut-être de ne
pas s'égarer dans des controverses
idéologique et de rester ce dont je suis
sûre concret et pragmatique un total à
20h50
merci pour la mort 20h50 audition
publique en italie la morale politique
est en train d'en prendre un grand coup
avec les enquêtes successives sur les
affaires de corruption dernière
arrestation en date d'une longue liste
celle d'un financier qui contrôle les
ciments français le deuxième groupe
cimentier de l'hexagone un os de
fonctionnaire soupçonné lui aussi de
corruption s'est d'autre part suicider
près de rome dernier scandale en date
celui qui entoure les magouilles autour
du dernier mondial de football
reportage de notre correspondant jean
louis le sel en italie rien n'est jamais
assez beau pour le football alors pour
faire honneur au sport roi
les italiens de 90 avait cru qu'il
pouvait tout faire de préférence dans le
luxe en utilisant bien sûr les deniers
publics
seulement en italie on ne sait pas ce
qu'est un appel d'offres équitable
en italie on ne sait pas ce qu'est un
contrat pour une livraison clé en main
résultat des devis doublé ou triplé que
les magistrats bolt est plus hachée et
des dessous de table que la justice
entend aujourd'hui est allé au grand
jour et sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est à dire dans les 12 grandes villes
hôtes du mondial dont rome
on disait à l'époque c'était une chance
unique pour la ville
en fait ça a été une chance unique pour
les spéculateurs et tous ceux qui
acceptaient le système des pots-de-vin
au total les grands travaux de la coupe
du monde de 1990 ont coûté sept mille
milliards de lires à l'état italien 23
milliards de francs
cela va de la construction de stades à
l'élargissement de route en passant par
la restructuration d'aéroports ou encore
la prolongation de lignes de chemin de
fer exemple le plus rocambolesque celui
de vignes à clara à rome la première
gare dans l'histoire du train placé sous
séquestre prix de revient 250 millions
de francs utilisation officiel dix jours
utilisation réelle quatre jours le
nouveau groupe électrogène rolls royce
500 kilowatts à fonctionner 2h13 c'est
écrit dessus
cela fait très cher du kilowatt et bien
d'autres équipements ferroviaires sont
aujourd'hui à l'abandon où on a
construit cette gare parce qu'on croyait
que c'était une anticipation du
programme plus général au contraire
l'argent est manquée et donc ça a été un
contredire un réseau s'est éclaté tard
dans le désert c'était ça parce qu'on a
pu on n'a pas pu on n'a pas eu la
disponibilité d'argent pour pouvoir
aller de l'avant
à rome les magistrats s'intéresse
surtout au stade olympique dont la
restructuration a coûté 860 millions de
francs déjà 29 personnes sont inquiétés
par la justice pour l'instant alors chao
la mascotte du mondial est en rage elle
elle mettait la clef pour le score un
français sur cinq pourrait être
considéré comme un raciste convaincu et
un français sur trois a paré tenté par
le racisme
telles sont les conclusions du rapport
de la commission consultative des droits
de l'homme
cela dit les actes de violence raciste
ont diminué l'an dernier en france alors
que paradoxe le racisme ordinaire entre
guillemets a au contraire tendance à se
banaliser commentaires marie durement
les français sont ils aujourd'hui plus
raciste qui hier c'est donc la question
à laquelle ce rapport tente de répondre
parlons d'abord de ce qui est rassurant
en 88
les services de police dénombrait 64
actes racistes grave
en 92 il en recense 28 soit beaucoup
moins
alors qu'en allemagne les attaques
contre des foyers d'immigrés sont en ce
moment fréquentes en france aujourd'hui
ce type de violence raciste est en
baisse mais les statistiques masque mal
quelques tendances de fond plus
inquiétant en effet d'après un sondage
réalisé pour les besoins de ce rapport
un français sur cinq peut-être
aujourd'hui qualifiés de racistes
convaincu et un français sur trois se
dit tenté par le racisme sont des gens
qui expriment ainsi une espèce de
ras-le-bol face à des difficultés de
cohabitation face à ce qu'ils croient
être une présence immigrée trop
importante et joue un rôle dans les
difficultés économiques et sociales
j'ai beaucoup expriment une espèce de
ras-le-bol en dix ans justement les
hommes politiques en parlait pas assez
nous redémarrons va le dire
d'après le rapport de plus en plus de
jeunes sont aujourd'hui tentés par les
sentiments xénophobes
c'est sans doute l'un des aspects du
rapport le plus inquiétant pour l'avenir
c'est évidemment hasard mais c'est
aujourd'hui que l'association présidée
par danielle mitterrand france libertés
a présenté son passeport européen contre
le racisme
reportage lorraine cusin fil du match en
france le racisme n'est pas une opinion
c'est un délit dans quelques jours cette
affiche le rappellera ce passeport toute
personne souhaitant s'engager
individuellement entre les actes
d'exclusion pourra se le procurer au
siège des associations antiracistes de
défense des droits de l'homme
la démarche est pratique le passeport
défini l'acte raciste il rappelle la
réglementation il indique la marche à
suivre aux victimes et témoins du
racisme
c'est beaucoup plus un appel à la
conscience à la conscience du respect
des autres est bon en france l'acteur
assists et puni par la loi
dans les autres pays
peut-être le deviendra t'il sous le
terme d'actes racistes mais tout le
travail de fond d'appels à la conscience
individuelle c'est vraiment l'essentiel
du message de se passer les associations
antiracistes vont tenter maintenant de
persuader le conseil de l'europe de
porter ce projet au niveau européen afin
d'en faire un véritable acte de
solidarité sociale nouveaux progrès dans
la connaissance des maladies génétiques
deux équipes françaises viennent en
effet d'identifier le gène d'une maladie
qui concernent chaque année en france
une cinquantaine d'enfants mais avec des
conséquences très très grave
cette maladie va sans doute devoir son
pronostic bouleversé et surtout cette
découverte ouvre une voie nouvelle dans
la recherche sur une maladie hélas
beaucoup plus fréquentes
la sclérose en plaques reportage jean
daniel flaysakier avec à strasbourg john
jehn bac à 10 ans gauthier vraiment très
loin de vivre la vie des garçons de son
âge tout cela parce qu'une maladie
l'adrénoleucodystrophie ou à elle des
faits que son système nerveux et peut un
peu détruit victimes des effets toxiques
d'un certain type de graisse ces
destructions sont liés au fait qu'un
gène est défaillant à l'intérieur de ces
cellules et ne peut permettre un
fonctionnement normal de son organisme à
l'état normal c'est grâce devrait être
absorbée par des véhicules que l'on
appelle le peroxyde home
une fois qu'elles sont en cp roxy somme
des substances des enzymes viennent les
détruire a porté par des protéines dans
la ld il y à bien les enzymes il n'ya
plus les protéines pour véhiculer ces
enzymes qui bien que ces grèves toxiques
peuvent s'accumuler dans l'organisme et
produire leurs effets néfastes
les chercheurs parisienne strasbourgeois
qui ont identifié le gène veulent
maintenant dans les années proches
arrivaient à apporter un traitement à
ses enfants
ils vont donc essayer d'amener par le
moyen d'un virus
le gène sain à l'organisme des petits
malades dans leurs globules blancs
l'idée de la thérapie génique c'est de
corriger le gène dans les cellules de
moelle osseuse du patient
et ensuite
de faire une greffe une transplantation
autonome c'est-à-dire comprendra la
propre moelle du patient pas besoin de
donneurs
pas besoin de donneurs donc possibilité
de faire la greffe à tous les patients
pour lequel elle sera indiquée pas de
risque d'orage et pas de risque de
réaction contre l'autre mais les
chercheurs sont aussi intéressés par une
autre perspective en effet les lésions
du cerveau constaté dans la ld sont très
proches de celles d'une autre maladie
la sclérose en plaques se seraient alors
des milliers de personnes qui seraient
concernées par cette recherche
une recherche qui vient sans doute de
franchir une nouvelle étape mauvais
payeurs gare à votre sacro sainte
voiture depuis le 1er janvier la loi
permet en effet aux huissiers 2 cloué
sur place votre voiture grâce au
démoniaque sabots de denvers si vous
êtes bien sûr un mauvais débiteur
valérie gager effet drake base ils ont
joué à la caméra cachée avec la
complicité d'un huissier petites
saynètes baptisé d'anvers et ses gros
sabots
il n'a ni qu'elle finit uniforme juste
un grand sac dans lequel il cache son
arme secrète une pantoufle du colorado
surnom donné par les québécois au bon
vieux sabots d'anvers eh oui monsieur si
vous avez des dettes qu'elle quelle soit
attention cet homme peut saisir en
chaussant désagréablement votre voiture
surprise à n'envoyer tout est bien garé
non non c'est plutôt pour pour la police
non je suis ici de justice et voilà ça
c'est pas pour les contraventions rien
du tout a saisi l'un des véhicules
et moi je suis vissé justice c'est pour
ça et voilà sans avoir à verser la
personne etc
voilà il mobilisait le monsieur s'est
également dit s'ils sont déjà des gens
qui ont par principe une mauvaise
réputation vous pensez pas qu elles vont
prendre encore un coup avec les savons
donc on a volé de réputation vrai qu'on
a une mauvaise image mais bon on doit
faire appliquer les décisions du juge la
loi nous donne ce moyen là on utilise la
récente décision peut relancer le marché
du symbole usine de stocks qui a mis au
point la pince française il y à 25 ans
et ce tant pis ces derniers modèles
façon justice le ca boudoussier est le
seul qui soit vraiment identifiable
une quarantaine d'études ont déjà
investi à raison de 1800 francs la
pantoufle
je n'ai pas eu de retombées encore je
sais à l'heure actuelle qui a induit
c'est qu'ils en avaient déjà fait
chaparder une
c'est certain maintenant à savoir s'il
était bien poser c'est autre chose
mission tout aussi impossible savoir si
jean yanne a déjà joué de la pince pour
enrichir sa fameuse collection thabo le
carnaval de rio millésime 93 a été
plutôt moins meurtrier que celui de l'an
dernier
il n'ya eu si j'ose dire que 80 de
personnes assassinées contre 84 l'an
dernier mais surtout beaucoup moins
d'accidents mortels sur les routes
alentour 87 tués contre 148 l'an dernier
sport toujours à la mi-temps monaco mène
1 but à 0 devant marseille
les dirigeants de la fifa ont annoncé
aujourd'hui que le grand prix de france
de formule 1 aurait bien lieu le 4
juillet sur le fameux circuit de magny
cours
c'est maintenant l'heure du show et même
du bernard shaw puisque nous allons
parler de sa pièce la plus célèbre
pygmalion mise en scène par bernard
murat au théâtre hébertot à la saint
rome et aux invités de ce journal le
couple qui représente la jeunesse et la
beauté
j'ai cité par ordre alphabétique sophie
marceau et lambert wilson
le mythe de pygmalion et bien sûr
universellement connu c'est pour résumer
l'histoire d'un homme qui veut façonner
une jeune femme à sa manière qui fera
semblant de se laisser faire pour mieux
prendre le dessus en fin de parcours
avant de rencontrer son mentor et lisa
est une modeste marchand de fleurs un
court extrait de ce spectacle c'est à
dire devenir une demoiselle dans un
média n'affleure lieu devant le centre
autour des personnages mais au moins
quinze rapport attendu n'a pas pesé
puisque comme il faut et bat pour ses
tenues il a dit qu'il pouvait
m'apprendre alors vas sur deux cours et
rien d'autre un tout prêt à le payer lui
demande pas de faveurs une trace comme
du côté de la grotte ben merde alors là
et maintenant dit après mois le quart
sud est de la côte sera influencé tant
par des résidus plus d'y est stagnant
sur le relief que par une dépression à
l'ouest de nos cils
jocard ci est elle aussi tombée parce
qu'il ya aucune importance je mets une
boîte pleine de
le quart sud est de la creuse a
influencé tant par des résidus pluvieuse
et revenant sur le relief que par une
dépression à l'ouest de nos îles
voilà vous avez reconnu bien sûr higgins
le jeune aristocrate et lecture elle
c'est lambert wilson et lisa la petite
boutique hier à l'accent du faubourg
c'est sophie marceau sophie et lambert
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous depuis
votre loge
j'espère qu'on vous entende et l'on ait
envie mais alors question classique
pourquoi avoir choisi ce classique du
répertoire et bien écoutez c'est parce
qu'on avait envie tout simplement ses
très jolies pièces des beaux personnages
et ça court pas les rues
alors voilà on s'est lancé là-dedans
d'avril sol vous semblez vous sentez en
osmose comme on dit quand on cause bien
avec ce ce personnage soit que c'est une
rencontre ce qui s'est passé en tout cas
aux jo de plus de trois jours et salah
de frapper tout le monde
une des rares les rencontres avec un
personnel je me sens effectivement très
préparé une tout mon côté anglais et
puis mon côté aussi un peu j'ai pas je
suis assez obsédé par les questions de
phonétique moi même mais j'aime bien
j'aime bien de préciser au passage que
j'adore faire tout ce qui est ce qu est
ce qui est intéressant c'est que c'est
une comédie c'est la première fois que
ce fut moi on joue une comédie d'un
grand classique
c'est un plaisir vous avez vu
dans l'extrait je veux dire la rencontre
avec le public est incroyable ça ça
c'est très très impressionnant
précisément c'est un texte très sérieux
qui fait allusion à des domaines
importants mais qui garde le ton de la
comédie et et vous rappeliez et que
bernard shaw justement envoyé dit on des
lettres tout à fait incendier aux
acteurs qui jouaient les rôles beaucoup
trop sérieusement et là on l'a vu ça rit
beaucoup dans la salle vous l'aï pris
côté comique
je crois que c'est inévitable dans la
mesure où c'est écrit comme ça ce sont
des grands à lui mais il ya une
situation qui est très remonté et puis
le temps ce qui est formidable et très
jouissif pour nous tous acteurs c'est
qu'il ya des arrière-plans sans arrêt et
qu'il ya en même temps quelque chose qui
est grinçant qui est révélateur des
rapports entre entre les hommes et les
femmes l'impossibilité dé des rapports
amoureux et c'est très fort puisque
c'est sucré et salé en même temps un
sauve qui opinent du bonnet et oui alors
c'est pas la première fois qu on vous
retrouve ensemble sur les planches vous
aviez joué au riz 10 d'anouilh et puis
vous aviez joué également pour le cinéma
les chouans de philippe de broca alors
si je vous demande comment ça se passe
la complicité entre vous deux je suppose
que vous allez me répondre que tout va
bien
non non mais pour parler de la pièce
c'est vrai que c'est une pièce contre
laquelle on ne peut pas à lutter c'est à
dire qu'il ya vraiment effectivement une
drôlerie une comédie un rythme rapide
amusant et puis il faut dire aussi qu'il
aime deuxième partie dans la pièce qui
est aussi plus plus tendu où les
émotions passent où il ya aussi beaucoup
de deux conflits entre ces deux
personnages qui qui soudain développe en
eux des des moments d'amour des moments
de de disputes qui sont qui sont qui
sont toujours dans la comédie mais qui
ont aussi la qualité d'être d'être
émouvante et c'est là la richesse de sa
seule famille deux dernières questions
sophie marceau vous avez fait sauf
erreur dix films en dix ans est ce que
c'est ça non non j'ai fait 4 c en treize
ans et pas un show télévisé
est-ce que vous avez plus de
satisfaction sur les planches que sur la
pellicule
non j'ai autant de plaisir et autant de
souffrances aussi bien pour l'un que
pour l'autre mais je considère que les
deux font partie du même métier est de
passer de l'un à l'autre et à mon avis
indispensable quand on quand on aime
quand on aime jouer
jamais jamais jamais aujourd'hui me
retrouver sur scène et je pense déjà au
prochain film que j'ai envie de faire il
faut dire une petite petite parenthèse
ce qu'on est très très bien entouré
parce qu'il ya des grandes et grands
pros du spectacle du théâtre de la
comédie qui sont michel duchaussoy
micheline boudet pierre de risque face à
des gens qui c'est une équipe vraiment
formidable voilà c'est très bien avoir
rendu hommage aux eaux parce que c'est
vrai qu'on n'y voit pas assez je vais
vous laisser puisqu'on vous appelle de
sciences et voudrait pas retarder et
rendre impatient les spectateurs du
théâtre hébertot vous rentrez sur scène
dans un instant bravo et bon courage
bonne soirée
merci beaucoup donc je rappelle
pygmalion au théâtre hébertot
avant de vous souhaiter une excellente
de soirée à l'écouté de nos programmes 7
toutes dernières informations en
provenance de nouvelle-zélande un
honorable père de famille a asséné un
coup de poing sur la tête de sa fille de
14 ans parce qu'il estimait qu'elle ne
se concentrait pas suffisamment sur la
lecture des saintes écritures
ce n'est pas une attitude chrétienne a
déclaré le juge en condamnant le papa à
trois mois et demi de prison
soirée plutôt contrasté sur france 2
après audition publique taratata de
nagui qui passe maintenant le jeudi soir
reçoit ce soir jane birkin 23h45 le
dernier journal philippe lefait bonne
fête aux romeo le dicton du jour février
neigeux était avantageux ça tombe bien
car météo france prévoit l'arrivée d'une
forte perturbation neigeuse laurent mais
ce que vous en dira plus dans quelques
instants
excellente soirée à toutes et à tous
merci à demain